У штабі Володимира Зеленського  святкують приголомшливу перемогу
і не стримують емоцій.
Свою промову переможець розпочав англійською.
Я почуваюся чудово. Дякую усім, дякую!
Будь ласка, не плачте!
Шоумен переміг чинного президента з величезним відривом.
За даними Національного екзит-полу,
Зеленський набрав 73% голосів виборців,
оді як Петро Порошенко - лише 25 з половиною.
Це найбільша різниця між фіналістами  президентських перегонів
за всю історію країни.
Перемогти чинного президента шоумену було легко,
адже українці прагнуть змін та хочуть бачити нові обличчя у владі,
зазначають оглядачі. Саме таким кандидатом
і виявився Зеленський - комік без політичного досвіду.
А незабаром - наймолодший глава держави
за всю історію незалежної України.
Йому лише 41 рік.
Усім країнам пострадянського союзу:
подивіться на нас - все можливо!
Змінити владу дійсно можливо,
якщо значна частина населення невдоволена
політикою чинної влади, і це вкотре засвідчила
перемога Зеленського, зазначають оглядачі.
Адже Україна після п'яти років президентства Порошенка
й надалі належить до найбідніших країн у Європі.
Корупцію та кумівство подолати не вдалося.
Як і завершити війну на Донбасі, що на початку своєї каденції
обіцяв чинний президент.
Усі ці проблеми тепер доведеться вирішувати Зеленському та його команді.
Його перемогу, а разом із нею і свою поразку
Петро Порошенко визнав.
Проте запевнив: йти з політики - не збирається.
Вже наступного місяця я
залишу пост глави держави.
Так вирішила більшість українців -
і я сприймаю це рішення.
Я піду з офісу,
але хочу твердо наголосити -
я не йду з політики.
Порошенко запевняє: готовий підставити плече
новому господарю Банкової в усіх його рішеннях,
які відповідатимуть національним інтересам України
і наближатимуть її до Євросоюзу та НАТО.
А допомога Зеленському, схоже, знадобиться,
адже політичну кухню шоумен знає лише за телесеріалом "Слуга народу",
в якому зіграв головну роль президента Голобородька.
Водночас, як Зеленський реагуватиме на реальні виклики,
і якими будуть його перші кроки,
конкретики поки замало.
Так само, як і стосовно того, хто обійме ключові посади в країні.
Українцям він лише пообіцяв "нових людей" у владі,
однак прізвищ поки не назвав.
Багато українців, особливо молодь,
сприймають Зеленського як нове обличчя на політичній арені України
на противагу представникам старого покоління.
Проте нова команда Зеленського поки є нечисельною.
А йому самому закидають тісні ділові та приватні стосунки
з олігархом Ігорем Коломойським.
Тож, хто керуватиме країною, остаточно стане зрозумілим
лише після парламентських виборів,
запланованих на жовтень цього року.
Або після можливих дострокових виборів,
якщо новий президент таки вирішить у травні розпустити Верховну Раду,
бо де-факто там вже давно немає коаліції.
Тоді українці й побачать, з якими політичними силами
співпрацюватиме новий президент.